my name is Matt Butler we're here to
talk about secure cutting best practices
so if that's not what you're here for
you're in the wrong room so there's a
couple over there that if you wanted to
go now this would be a good time ten
minutes from now might be slightly
awkward a little bit about me this is
actual my first time at this conference
I've spent most of the last three
decades in national defense law
enforcement network security so writing
systems that either protect against
these kinds of vulnerabilities or
penetrations or actually having to be
defended from them this talk came
largely out of the experiences that I've
had for the last thirty years or so I
hope everybody's awake because we have
two hundred and seventy five slides and
a demo I'm just kidding we only have
about 50 slides we do have a demo but
the talk is interactive interrupt ask
questions this is more of a conversation
because everybody here is affected by
the material that we go over just as a
show of hands how many of you have some
sort of secure coding or secure security
testing going on in the environments
that you work in ok that's about normal
most people don't because we don't think
about this so this is I think our
biggest problem I love the look on the
Eagles face it's like really Tinker Bell
that's how you want this to end but it
sort of shows the way we think about
hackers we have a tendency to think of
ourselves as the cat because we feel
like they're the ones who control the
engagement they're the ones who decide
what happens what we forget is that
we're the ones who own the software we
own the network we own the environment
we control the engagement and that's
what this talk is really about the only
thing they get to choose is the timing
so there's three lies that I've told
myself over my career all of which have
to do with this the first thing is well
my codes been reviewed
and we've all told ourselves that right
after a big bug is found you know why
didn't get caught in the code review my
code runs behind a firewall I don't have
to worry about security the problem is
the new law of the jungle is is that
being behind firewalls not going to
protect you
the last one is we're to whatever to be
a target we're too small we're too big
we're too remote we don't have anything
anybody wants the reality is is none of
that is true every company has money so
at a very minimum they'll be coming
after the money what's really I think
distressing about the way penetrations
are happening is really the motivation
behind it and the FBI tends to be
concerned about this too because we're
going to a much darker place than we've
been before it used to be that hacking
was just about the money it might have
been a nation-state was looking for
technology but what we're seeing is a
lot more penetrations into things that
have to do with people's safety
last year DHS managed to hack into a
Boeing 757 and Boeing's responses we're
not afraid of flying which is wonderful
considering they're probably not flying
a 757 at the time but the fact that they
could get into an aircraft and get into
its vital systems in in this case it was
sitting on the ground doesn't really
give us much comfort when two years
earlier a passenger had managed to hack
into almost 20 aircraft that he was on
not necessarily getting into the flight
controls but getting close enough to the
flight controls that if somebody did
that you could bring down the jetliner
to give you the example the FBI right
now it used to be when you did a felony
car stop you get a car in front car and
back car on the side and you basically
boxed in now they just send out a signal
get close enough to you send out a
signal they turn off the engine they
lock your doors and they deploy your
airbags and that's how they take you
down today no more having to do anything
physical so we're developing a whole
host of vehicles and transportation that
are connected to upstream servers almost
daily or at the 24 hours a day to the
point
if you can penetrate that upstream
server you can now get down into the
machinery of the vehicle and that's the
the part that is really that's the scary
part so the most dangerous real estate
on the planet is not in Syria it's not
in the Middle East it's not in North
Korea it's the internet because at no
time in our history has it been possible
for a single individual or a small group
of individuals to be able to launch an
attack all the way around the world
against a country against it's critical
infrastructure like its banking its
finance its power systems with little
ability for that government to respond
they can literally do it from their from
their living room with their pajamas on
what I can tell you after 30 years in
this business is perimeter Security's
not gonna protect you you need it
because it raises the bar the same
reason why you lock your doors but what
we find is that the bad guys have the
best hardware and software the money
that other people's money can buy so
they go and they take down a company
they pull 20 grand out if they go buy
the hardware ten they need they have all
the time in the world to go and practice
penetrating that particular firewall or
that particular network what I always
hear when I talk about when I talk about
this with somebody like a somebody in
the higher up and management is there is
this perception that your odds of being
targeted or very low that's just a
perception because the way we scale
software that we write directly
translates the way you can scale
penetrations into a system once I have
my package I can go and I can put it
against any company that I want or as
many companies as I want looking for
those vulnerabilities and it cost me
nothing to be able to go on to those
next companies but what I always tell
them is that you may have a low chance
of being penetrated but it's like being
shot in the head when it happens it's
going to be a disaster what we as
technologists have to understand
especially if we're writing stuff that's
running on hardware or if it's running
inside of a system and it doesn't have
anything out
facing is that there are any safe spaces
anymore they're going to get into your
prayer there is an entire laundry list
of companies that had outstanding
perimeter security and they all got
penetrated and they got into their inner
workings and what they'll do is when
they get inside they're gonna be there
for a while before you'll even find out
that they're and they're going to first
thing they're gonna do is build in back
doors so that they can get back in and
when you do find them they're going to
keep building back doors as long as you
haven't gotten them completely out
because then it becomes a race and while
they're in there they're gonna do some
pretty horrible things to you so let's
talk about the Veii so nation-states any
come any nation state that has
geopolitical or geo military ambitions
has an offensive hacking system or
program it becomes one of those keep
your enemies close keep your friends
closer they'll hack anybody that's just
the way they do it what be what I think
is really most scary is just simply that
when they find these exploits they will
weaponize them so they can deploy them
easily into the field but then those
weaponized exploits get into the hands
of the second group which is crime
syndicates people who are looking for
money they're looking for technology in
every country that has internet access
has them the third group we talked about
that we often don't think about is
business-to-business know Nortel
Networks has the distinction of being
sort of the poster child of having been
driven into bankruptcy by a competitor
who is actually in their networks for
almost about 10 years they were into
everything their executives emails their
business plans they knew exactly what
when they would have to go after a
contract they knew exactly what they
were going to propose for that contract
how much they were going to ask and so
this in this competitor was constantly
under bidding them on their contracts
eventually it led them into bankruptcy
and that's an example what we call an
advanced persistent threat you've been
penetrated they're in there for a very
long time and they're doing lots of
damage to your company and then I put
the fourth one on here mainly just
because
for completeness but strangely enough we
talk about all of these data breaches
but in reality it's the insiders that
are responsible for most of the data
breaches people who are already in
positions of trust who take that
information and either go to another
company sell it to a competitor or in
the cases of espionage to another
government so that's not one where to
talk or log out say simply because
there's not a lot we can do about it
it's not the system's we right it's not
the Coby right that really does anything
that can affect that so we have some
terms we need to to discuss the first is
what is a critical system well there's
the system itself we have the system
that allows us to do whatever we're
holding credit card data bank data we're
holding something of value that somebody
wants but it also includes the other
systems that can interact with that
system no matter how low priority those
systems are so processes that are
unrelated hardware like printers
external systems anything that can talk
or in any way interact with that
particular system has to be considered
part of a critical system so the next
thing we have to define is what is an
attack vector
so buffer overruns as far as our code
bases is still absolutely the number one
and the most devastating attack you can
launch against somebody the same thing
with code pointer expert exploits
because they allow you to run arbitrary
code on somebody else's system move ever
fashionable moving up as a denial of
service that's usually undefined
behavior I send you garbage data your
system chokes on it it goes down it
resets I send you the same data again
and you just keep doing this over and
over again so your system doesn't work
there are others like sequel injection
attacks that's number one on the OWASP
top 10 a waswas an organization that
talks about that deals with web facing
applications so if you're writing
JavaScript you probably already know
about a wasp today I'll walk you through
a using a buffer overrun to run a
privilege escalation attack against a
Linux box and then we'll do it live I've
got a VM that we can do it on
the important thing when it taught when
we talk about attack vectors is that
getting into a system is kind of like an
air disaster there's never one thing
that brings down a jet and there's never
one thing that allows somebody into your
system it's usually a chain of events
that if you can break the chain you
avert the disaster so when we talk about
code one of things we'll talk about
today is this where the vulnerability is
tells you how important this is if it's
something down in the kernel level it's
something you absolutely have to deal
with if it's something in a low priority
system with very few privileges maybe
that's something you're you can you
don't have to be as worried about that
but when you're talking about you but
you always have to look at what what the
system does and what its privileges are
the next thing is attack surfaces so
attack surfaces any external facing
interface so if you're running any kind
of web system or if you if you have any
kind of input from somebody the attack
surface is gonna be your network
connections user interfaces
authentication points USB isn't the
attack surface so somebody sends out a
mailer one of your employees gets it hey
it's a free USB we're just trying this
out what's their first impulse tear it
open let's take this thing for a drive
the problem is is that it that is just
not become an attack surface into your
system and since they're logged on with
a reasonably privileged account whatever
privileges they have that virus can now
use it as well but it's also our
internal interfaces how many people here
write systems that have multiple
processes that have to talk to each
other yeah almost everybody but none of
us really do anything to protect our IPC
traffic we don't do anything to
authenticate it
well no but most of us don't I'm sure
there are exceptions to it especially if
you're for the product lines you're in
but the other thing is CL is I come from
the hardware world one of the things we
would always do is we go drop these nice
little CLI down on the hardware that
ships so that the field engineers can do
the things they need to do except we
don't authenticate those at all so
somebody comes in and what's the first
thing we do when you type a CLI gives
you a nice usage chart oh I didn't know
that would allow me to go ahead and
reset the system I'll just write a
little script that just sits in
perpetually resets your system
command-line interface so the question
was what to CLI CLI is a command-line
interface if you have a process that may
be listening on IPC port but you want to
be able to do things outside of the UI
you would drop a another binary on this
it's a CLI that actually talks into that
IPC for it and it's got it uses char
that gives you things that you can do
telnet yeah so the first the first place
we have to go is that we build security
in layers in the same way that you have
perimeter security that's not the only
line of security what you when you when
we talk about securing a an environment
you build the Securities and layers and
for us and what we're talking about
today the last layer is the code itself
so let's look at some code I picked
these out of the common vulnerability
databases because I was really just
looking for things that I thought were
interesting and that would sort of tell
a story so I didn't come up with these
these or not that I meant to be tricky
that they are vulnerabilities that we do
know exist in in current code so what's
the vulnerability with this exactly yes
this is a buffer overflow because we
don't know and we don't test to see
whether link actually fits in that
buffer size now the the box on the right
actually comes from cert so the top one
is the severity this is perhaps one of
the most buffer overflows of the most
devastating if you can make it work it's
one of the most devastating things you
can do to a system the second one is the
likelihood so this is highly likely we
missed this a lot and then the
remediation is the the medium so how do
we remediated code so we could use
standard string I mean it's
it's heap-allocated it's not on the
stack unless it's a small string but I
think they got rid of the small string
implementation when we put him move
semantics good passes code review ship
it any problems right but I'm also
assuming well let's assume the string is
valid because most buffer overflows are
null terminated because you don't want
to you don't want when it's trying to do
the buffer overflow for it to mess up so
you do an alternate the problem here is
actually that we have it in a heap
allocated string but we're actually
going back to something that's gonna be
sitting on the stack again because we're
calling C string so we're actually
passing this into something that's going
to put this back into a stack somewhere
or may potentially deeper down so all
you're doing if you do this is just
deferring the bug you're pushing this
farther down in the stack and you will
lose sight of where that code actually
came from so a better choice here is if
you're gonna error out then check the
links and error out because it may be a
valid string but it's just too long but
then go ahead and null terminated into
the buffer a null terminator and be done
with it if you pass it into a string you
never know where it's going to wind up
yeah I'm just dealing with the buffer
overflow at this point I know it's a
null terminator and it fits in my buffer
so I can't overflow the stack here yeah
I'm going to walk you through a buffer
overflow exploit and then we're gonna
run one live in a VM if we have time
where we use a privilege escalation
attack to get go look at say the shadow
file which you shouldn't be able to look
at
how about this one right exactly you may
not be in this enumeration yeah so it's
this one which is undefined behavior now
this changed in C++ 17 this became
undefined behavior before it was an
unspecified value so that makes this a
little more dangerous than it used to be
so we can remediate this by using
something we already have in modern C++
which is a strongly typed enumeration
and tell it's an integer if it's outside
the integer we don't care it still fits
in an integer we're not overflowing
anything we're not doing as long as this
is an integer being passed in then we
don't have a vulnerability to let's try
to well you're gonna check the range at
some other point but it's not going to
do anything bad because you're pushing
an integer into an integer so the
problem here is you're using an
enumeration that comes from the for
modern C++ so you have no way of knowing
because you're not doing the check until
after this enumeration
you have no way of knowing how the
compiler is going to interpret that and
it becomes undefined behavior right may
have this is a medium vulnerability this
is going to cause undefined behavior and
this is not going to overflow unless
you're talking about passing something
much much bigger in your compiler and
how badly you wrote the code and all
that because transfer let's pick on stay
on separate libraries from it
it's alright forget to repeat the
question yep in fact that's the problem
and this is actually a buffer overflow
on the heat because you have and that's
a high severity because you're not in
fact dest is actually zero
you haven't allocated anything yet but
you're just copping into what amounts to
an empty vector so the remediation that
just do a reserve or like you said due
back inserter but you have to it's an
easy mistake to make because unless
you've read copy you won't know that
copies and actually not doing an insert
copy is actually just doing a memory
copy okay so yeah so my screen cut my my
screen code has a bug in it the other
thing you could do is just go ahead and
and create it in that in the constructor
create the size where yous back inserted
with a destination beacon or takes takes
us aside yeah so and I don't think I did
I didn't do a slide that head back
insert around there I just had it in my
notes the other thing is standard fill
and standard transform I'll do the same
thing so you have to make sure that
you've allocated the right amount of
space for it how about this one so this
is this is what we'd see a lot in legacy
code why that's entirely possible that's
not the vulnerability I was thinking
about the vulnerability I was thinking
about is this wild statement doesn't
ever terminate if you don't pass a zero
so it simply keeps going on and on this
is actually a pretty good vulnerability
that's very hard for static analysis
tools to catch because they have no idea
what data is being passed in here
so no you're passing in a range of
values right but that while Luke was
waiting for a zero to terminate the wild
loop if they don't ever get a zero it
just keeps going on and on and on okay
so the comment was is that it is the
responsibility of the caller to make
sure that what they're passing is
correct
I agree but they very often don't so
there are some facilities within C++
modern C++ that allow us to get away
from this so for example you use a very
attic template you can also use brace
initializer list expansion so this is a
case where the newer facilities of the
language actually help us to get out of
some of the problems that we've seen in
the older parts of the languages like
especially in some of the C stuff that
you see in legacy code I think it's the
last one yep so it's undefined to here
where we don't know when that lambdas
going to be called so we're passing
something by reference that won't exist
probably at the time that that lambda is
called it's easy to overlook especially
with people who are unfamiliar with
lambdas and haven't spent a lot of time
with them but this is actually depending
on how this is structured this becomes a
code pointer exception where you can
actually run an exploit off of this to
actually run arbitrary code so in this
case you capture of a value we're not
really using I anyway we're just setting
it to something else so let's talk about
a buffer overflow exploit if you've if
we've gone through if you've paid
attention to the what we've the five
examples we went through every one of
them come down to one thing and that is
we've lost it to a situational awareness
on our data we're just acting on data
without actually having done anything to
it to verify that that data is
we balance and I'll go ahead and give
you part at the end of the talk if you
want to make your code as hardened
against attack as possible that is the
one thing you can do is validate your
data know what you're working on
that 85% 90% of all the vulnerabilities
come down to this we've lost long
wareness on our data so let's look at a
buffer overflow so we have some really
badly written code it's the same code we
saw before and we want to do is find a
way to leverage that vulnerability now
we do a couple things we can crash the
system so we just put junk in and the
system will go down and that makes a
pretty decent denial of service we can
also execute arbitrary code so this is
the arbitrary code I would like to
execute this is for a Linux box the part
on the right is just sort of a C
representation of what we're trying to
do we're just trying to write shell once
we can get out and execute a shell we
have access to whatever privileges that
application has it doesn't seem like a
big vulnerability but some of the
biggest vulnerabilities and Linux were
parts of the operating system that ran
is root or as a high privileged account
that someone could run a buffer overflow
attack against it now they had root
access to the box and that's what we're
going to do the part on the right is
just the this is just the assembly code
that comes out and what we deal with is
we've got EBX ECX EDX and EAX which are
just the four pieces you need to setup
that you would see right there in that
execute statement 11 is just the system
call we're not sending any environment
variables and those last two have to do
with where you go and find what you're
going to execute so let's look at our
memory this is a traditional x86 so this
is an intel architecture if you're on
Sun workstations it's going to be a bit
different
Milou sides you've got text and data
that's the user space where programs run
the heap is on the bottom grows up the
kernel is that the top can't write there
either the stack is at the top it grows
downward the important thing to remember
though is
even though the stack grows downward
what it starts out is main and then and
then you grow your stack down where all
the memory is still access the
traditional way it's still from low
memory to high I pulled out just to give
you the to show you what a stack frame
would look like so everything in the
gold I took out some of the elements
it's just that I want to keep the
important things the gold would might be
main or whatever called you what's below
would be whatever you called or nothing
if you if you're at the bottom of the
stack so we have our nice big buffer the
EBP II rbp that's just the frame pointer
and then the return statement though
that's what really interests us because
there's an address in there and that
address in there is the next code to be
written after you hit return so as soon
as your function exits the address that
that return is going to be where the the
system goes to run the next piece of
code so what we would like to do the way
a buffer overflow works is is we'd like
to somehow change that address to point
back to someplace where we now have code
sitting that we want to execute which is
our shell code so what we're gonna do
and I know this takes a little
explaining we're going to use what's
called a no op slide so we could do this
one of two ways we have to hit this
return and we want to point that to
somewhere else but we really don't want
to have to have two very specific places
where we hit yeah the question we will
get to that and in fact in my demo I had
to disable all that so the so the
question was I thought that Intel and on
all these architectures had things to
prevent you from doing exactly what
we're doing and that is true and I'll
explain what they what they've put in
and how you can make sure that your code
is actually being executed under those
because it does make a difference it
doesn't eliminate it you can still get
around it
is just a lot harder so here we have we
know where the bottom of this buffer is
but we're gonna have to try and figure
out where that return statement is and
that's actually gonna come into play a
little bit later when we go through the
demo but what we want to do is we want
to hit that return statement and we want
to point somewhere where our code is but
we don't have to be exact it's hard
enough to get one exact address it's
really hard to get two exact addresses
out of this so what we use is called the
no op slides this no op slide is going
to be hex 90s in your buffer because
when the program pointer hits that and
starts executing it's just gonna bypass
all those no-ops until they get some
code that it can run which actually is
right about here so here's the beginning
of the exploit and then there's a big
block of what looks like the same
address over and over again so the
reason why you do that is because we're
not talking about pinpoint bombing here
we don't want to have to guess each
little piece on line because then it
becomes obvious because everything if
you overflow this and you blow up the
stack frame you crash the program and
we'd like to crash it as few times as
possible because the goal is not to
crash the program the goal is to be able
to use our exploit so we will fill that
with a big chunk of the same address
which in this case is just going to
point back into the buffer hits the no
op slide Goes Down execute our code so
in older systems and this is going to be
like early 2000s they've put a lot of
this infrastructure and to protect about
this it has not come in until like the
early 2000s into the BIOS in the
operating system so everybody understand
that part of it remember the 90s because
that becomes important when it comes to
finding out if somebody's trying to
penetrate your system and I'll show you
how that works here in a little bit so
to your question the things that have
been put in so since then we've added a
with a SLR which is the address
basically a layout randomization you I
went ahead and put all the the command
line switches for GCC clang and Visual
Studio now a SLR is actually turned on
by the operating system if you get root
access somehow you can go turn it off so
that's one thing that the
Vence them from each time you run the
application your address base is gonna
look slightly different because you'll
as you can imagine I start at the top of
the buffer and I start here oh that's
not it and I go a little further that's
not it go a little further and then
suddenly I've hit it but if the address
randomization is in play that they have
a hard time doing that at this point we
also have stack arts thing you can do a
stack guard yourself if you really want
to a stack cards really just an area of
memory all right the top of the stack
that has an own bit pattern and if that
known bit pattern has changed you know
that they somebody has tried to overrun
your stack
or you've done it accidentally but
somebody has corrupted your stack so and
we'll talk about safe stack a little bit
further down the presentation but those
are all the command line switches now
all of these are turned on by default so
make sure if in your build environments
that nobody has gone and turned any of
these off because you could be running
with this on your desktop where you're
doing development but in your CI builds
or in your your full build you may wind
up not having that so what can we do
about all this that that's just did
everybody understand that example of how
that works how do you at the buffer over
from so I have a buffer that is a fixed
width I give you a string that is much
longer than that width it's null
terminated no you are I'm giving you the
data you're putting it into something on
the stack you're not validating that the
length fits your buffer like the first
example we had so we just rights and
rights and rights until it hits an old
terminator yeah so the question is is
how do you wind up doing this and the
answer is is that you wind up not
handling the data correctly and you're
right it's on the interface and we'll
talk about trust boundaries here a
little bit later yeah
for example a function is called alkanes
local buffer and then tries to load an
image to that buffer and images received
over the network if the image is too
large then the buffer gets overflowing
the return addresses
overflown and when the function returns
from the step that corrupted the Genesis
is finished and okay so the comment was
probably a lot longer for me to repeat
but the basis was is it doesn't
necessarily have to be an interface
coming from the outside that a user is
going to have access to it could be an
interface of bringing a file over a over
a network so for example open ssl and
its heartbleed buff vulnerability was a
buffer overflow but it had nothing to do
with the user it was just two computers
talking and one of them happened to have
a payload in it that overflowed that
buffer you can do the same thing by
injecting something in a database the
fact that's part impartial the sequel
injection attack is I stick something in
that whether it comes from a database or
it comes from somewhere else I stick
something in that sequel call that
allows me to run arbitrary code so all
of these vulnerabilities then I'm still
surprised when I see that sequel
injection attack is that the attacks are
at the top of the list simply because
it's been there for over a decade on
Oahu's top ten it just becomes a case
that we don't think when we write code
of how it could be exploited so we're
told like for example in string copy
don't you string copy okay we don't use
string copy but we use string and copy
but we use it incorrectly and what we
can sort of understand is that we've
we've been given a language here that's
actually fairly safe just in the way
it's actually created it's just the way
we use it can create these
vulnerabilities for us so did that get
your question okay
so
yeah that's true my meat yeah so so
let's talk about what we can do about it
so sons who said that all battles are
won or lost before they ever fought
because it's all about the planning and
it's all about the preparation it's all
about the intentions so what we're going
to talk about now is what are the things
we can do to protect our systems against
people trying to penetrate them so I
took I hear I I love the core guidelines
I use it all the time
I love client ID I use it all the time
CPP check I use all of these all the
time but I wanted to go see how many of
these vulnerabilities would they pick up
and the answer was none the own yeah
this originally was a none until I
realized that in Clank ID almost all the
security checks were turned off by
default so in order to catch that one
and that's not even really the bad one
because that's sort of the problem with
static analyzers is that what happens
when you have too many false positives
in your static analyzer you turn it off
yeah so it's understandable that no one
really wants to catch this because all
the legacy code out there you would just
be getting these blizzards of false
positives so what this tells us is as
good as the poor guidelines are as good
as CPP check is as goes client ID and
the static analysis are we have to have
something more so let's look at secure
coding static analysis tools so there's
some commercial products Coverity and
sonar and these are all based on known
vulnerability databases from either cert
or OWASP or there's a database
maintained by mitre for the government
and you can actually go look and see
which ones which vulnerabilities they'll
catch in this case I also I went and
looked at their vulnerability APA
databases to find out if they would have
caught any of these bugs and they don't
cover any of them and then we have the
thread safety analysis we'll talk about
that one a little bit later rows
checkers which is specifically designed
for the cert C and C++ vulnerabilities
the problem here is is that you have to
build with your rows
compiler and what they've provided is a
VM that you can run their checkers on
which is a little hard to use so I'm
pretty sure it's not gonna get a whole
lot of traction except in the
environments where people are actually
using it you have the AR energy model
which it's looking for integer overflows
in your code or potential energy
overflows then you have compiler and
forced buffer overflow elimination which
is really in the research stages so then
it becomes the question is why don't we
have a lot of static analysis tools
since that would seem to be the thing we
really want to do is catch this at at
compile time and this is exactly it that
the comment was it's hard it's just
indicative that is a very very hard
problem the reason why we don't think
it's hard the reason why we have people
who are able to say oh well this is the
vulnerability that I'm seeing here is
because the very best pattern-matching
recognition pattern recognition system
you will ever have is your own brain if
you go back and look at what little kids
that are six months old can do and the
patterns they can recognize it's almost
stunning the way our brains work and
especially the way it processes
information doing machine learning on
this so the question is is there anybody
doing machine learning on this I don't
know but I think there's enough tools
out there that even if we can't catch
this at compile time there's tools we
can catch in our CI builds we can catch
it and we can then we can actually put
in our build environments to catch a lot
of these vulnerabilities for us so I
don't know that anybody's really taking
the time to do that the biggest thing
you have to remember about static
checkers is they're based on their rules
and their rules are sometimes very hard
to write going and fine and just
gripping for you know string copy that's
easy and then there's your rule but
there's a lot of behavior because they
can't handle things like architectural
vulnerabilities they they don't know
what the data is that's coming in static
checkers really don't have the ability
to catch everything they can catch some
of the easy stuff but they don't have
you build in which means we need
something more
so what has been developed here in the
last few years has is a series of
sanitizers I don't know about Windows
I'm sure they have their own things but
I do more Linux development that I do
anything else so these are the ones I'm
familiar with so you have address
sanitizer which handles things like
buffer overflows and thread sanitizer
which is for concurrency so there's
these four sanitizers that when you turn
them on and you're running them they
will look into your code and watch as
your code executes to look for these
kinds of patterns but these actually
need to be used with fuzz testing and if
anybody was in Marshalls talk earlier
today he's an excellent talk on fuzz
testing if you weren't OS fuzz is
actually googles continuous fuzzing
service so if you have an open source
project you can submit it to them they
will constant they will you have to set
up your own fuzz testing but what they
do is they run the fuzz tests against it
if they find a vulnerability they're
going to give you 90 days to fix it
before they publish it and if if you do
another commit to your repository
they'll automatically run on the new
commit which is a great surface
especially if anybody in here is doing
open source lib fuzzer is usually what
they use and that's coverage guided
fuzzing and what's interesting about
that is it will actually learn based on
the reflexes of your code so as you're
going in you will try one thing and
depending on the output whether it fails
or passes it will adjust itself slightly
American fuzzy lab uses genetic
algorithms that might be more way we
were talking about here is using genetic
algorithms things that can learn machine
learning to actually learn how your
system works I've heard fuzzy lop was
actually used to find the heartbleed
vulnerability actually found it fairly
quickly so we have dynamic analysis
tools that we can run after the fact but
what you find in these is that it's
really going to be as good as your test
cases or as good as the test harnesses
that you're using if you're not using
anything I would try either one of these
you will have to write test pictures for
them so you'll have to have the entry
points you'll have to and
it will handle the testing but so it
does take some work on our time it's not
the value-added is not free for for this
but they are really great tools the
combination of the two is oh you over
ran your buffer right here so they will
so the sanitizer you will be able to
tell you where you have undefined Bay or
where you have buffer overflow where you
have resource contention but we need to
go a little bit further because one of
the things for all of these things what
they do is they test the code and they
test the codes reflexes depending on
what you put into it but what they don't
test is your architecture and we talked
about CL eyes and we talked about IPC
mechanisms now once you're inside the
wire if your IPC mechanisms aren't doing
anything to authenticate or anything to
test to see who that data is coming from
is valid your open up to a do s attack
from within your own environment so
penetration is actively looking for
vulnerabilities and testers and it
really is sort of a different way of
thinking if you need to be frightened or
scared marginally terrified go to DEFCON
one of the one of the pieces of advice
you get when you go to DEFCON is leave
your electronic devices at home oh yeah
go take a burner phone that's that was
the comment it's take a burner phone
these the people that go to DEFCON are
absolute masters at penetrating a system
I had one of my staff a few years ago
and he was outstanding I've never known
anybody that could pull the system apart
and look and see and be able to know
what was going on inside that system
there's a lot of people there that a lot
of people to go there are people who who
actually do whitehat testing so they're
going to go in and they're gonna
penetrate your system and show your
system where the vulnerabilities are
because what we find is that most of the
vulnerable is actually start at the
architecture stage because we're not
really architecting for security we're
acting for performance we want
functionality we want scalability so we
want we don't think about security as an
aspect at all or even after we've put
the SystemVue now the third bullet point
I actually thought
long and hard before I put that in there
is let the hackers help this is not my
company speaking I'm this is not their
advice this is my personal advice you
could if you wanted to find out how
quickly your system could be penetrated
to set up a honeypot don't make it a
segment off your network
don't put it inside your firewalls
that's happened it's a physically
separated network it's got your system
in it but it has garbage data in it
you'll be surprised how when you publish
this and it's out there how fast people
will come and try and penetrate it I'm
in this game and a game which lot of
people are very good at but you're gonna
find out just how quickly your system is
going to get penetrated where they're
going to go but you make sure it's a
physically separated entity and
obviously get your company's position
before it again this is my personal
suggestion I'm not speaking on behalf of
any company I work for or at work or in
the past or will work for in the future
oh yeah so the comment is I don't need
to do what okay so the comment was is
you don't need to subject your company
to this and put it inside go put it
outside the wire just put it on the
network somewhere unless somebody again
that the person who did this for an
article got hacked in five minutes
awesome what's really interesting is
that when you go find out where all the
IPS that the attackers are coming from
it's sort of interesting to find that
security video anybody here do
test-driven development well just a few
so for those of you who don't do
test-driven development or don't like
testing driven development
it's basically way of taking your class
writing all the test cases so that they
fail failing them and then come back and
write the code that makes all the test
cases pass you could do the same thing
with security video that's really an
offshoot of fuzzing but you're doing it
in a much
your stage this is at the unit test
level of so this is when you're doing
your build and you're running your unit
test before your commit you're going to
commit your code go beyond fuzz testing
so fuzz testing especially for these is
very good at finding patterns but
there's other things that fuzz testing
doesn't handle like for example none of
those fuzzers really handles traffic
that is of particularly light like json
or xml so if you're writing something
that takes those you're going to have to
do this at the DVD level and write your
own test cases that send malformed
plushy more malformed data into your
class to make sure that it doesn't choke
now the one problem we all have as
engineers we've all been there is that
we write this pretty piece of code we
have this wonderful solution we're very
proud of it we've tested it it's held up
it's done all the things that it's
supposed to do but when it comes to
testing is we're really bad about just
hammering on our own code there is a we
call it confirmation bias I write the
tests that make sure my code pass I'm
not doing it intentionally that's just
the way human beings are wired together
don't test your own code give your code
to somebody else and let them go and do
mean things to it and and this is a much
harder and I put this on here and we'll
talk a little bit more about this a
little bit later is don't allow release
dates control your testing it's very
easy and if you work in an agile world
ok I've got my two-week sprints but
somebody has made a commitment to the
market out here and what we tend to do
even an add your world is we tend to
sacrifice quality upfront and then we
try and get all the testing in sort of
at the end and then of course QA gets
hammered I mean we all know that happens
to the waterfall world but when you've
made a commitment out here to the market
you're really putting yourself into a
waterfall model even if you're doing
two-week iterations there has to be
something in your testing that says we
have to get to this point and some bugs
are worse than others
vulnerabilities I don't know what your
severity rankings are one for
places where I've worked is is the worst
so you have to make sure that those sev
one bugs are not the things that can be
deferred any vulnerability is a certain
one until somebody comes back and says
yeah it's actually a low probability
that we can that they can get this it's
going to have a low impact on the system
so here we talked into some of the
things we can actually do as far as
writing our code so how many of us use
third-party libraries use open source
libraries guess what the bad guys use
open source libraries too in fact they
go do code reviews and run fuzz testing
against it because they want to find out
where the vulnerabilities are so when
they find out that you're using it
they'll know how to go and exploit your
code so one of the things that you can
do is writing security wrappers for your
third-party libraries so I have some
library that it's it's a hardware
dependent library I can't get through I
can't do anything with without using
this library but you can write a
security wrap around it that validates
the data that comes in and comes out and
also handles exceptions now I know
especially in my domain and hardware we
have a tendency to turn off exceptions
because we think they're bad the problem
is what we're turning off is our ability
to do something about the exception not
turning off the exception itself there
are some things in standard separate
libraries and I use them in the embedded
world for example if you pop off of an
empty vector it's going to throw and oh
is it now undefined baver well it
doesn't throw an exception that's
interesting okay because I have I have
one throw an exception on me the
advantage okay so what I'm hearing from
somebody who's on the standard committee
is its undefined beef okay
sorry I made this they're not on the
standard committee what you want to make
sure is that if something in that
library has the potential to throw like
being out of memory then you can catch
that exception without it bubbling the
top of your call stack and you pay for
their crimes trust management we're
talking about validating data the
reality is is we can
validate data at every possible step as
we're getting it because then we're
gonna spend most of our time validating
the same piece of data over and over and
over again what we can do is create a
concept of a trust boundary so in the
world that I work I've got a JavaScript
front-end I've got a c-plus was back in
the Java Script is sending me
information
now the Java Script are great guys
actually sometimes I'm going writes the
JavaScript but I don't always sanitize
my data so if I build a trust boundary
between my C++ code and the Java Script
then that means that I don't really
trust anything it's sending me and I
validate everything that comes in
through those interfaces what that means
is is that for example if we sending
something that's an enumeration I've
checked to make sure that it's valid and
I have to have an error state to go back
to tell the JavaScript side that what
they sent me is invalid I validate
lengths I mean they're putting in the
first name and last name and someone
puts this massive string in there the
JavaScript side probably doesn't care
and then it sends it to me I need to
validate it at the point of entry so
what I do is I treat everything that
comes out of that as foreign data even
if it's my own code that way I'm sure
that that data has been validated the
minute comes in what you want to avoid
is duplicate validation steps so what
you're going to do is you're going to
take these you're not going to build
these at every layer you're going to
build the data that every interface that
comes in is going to validate it once
and then inside your code so that you're
not constantly revalidating the same
piece of data over and over again you're
sure that what you have is valid so we
also have the embed you heard of the
principle of least privilege everybody
heard of it okay so the principle of
least privilege says is that you run
with the minimum amount of privileges
necessary in order to do what you need
to do but there are times when for
example that you need an additional
privilege so you will
grant yourself that privilege but then
what happens a lot of times is we forget
to revoke it when we have an exception
or when we have an error and it becomes
the same the same problem we had with
with locking mutexes and then suddenly
you error out and you didn't unlock it
and now we have our ai ai
this is a place where if you're going to
grant yourself additional privileges use
RIAA to make sure that once you've
exited out of that context that that
privilege gets revoked because there's a
lot of vulnerabilities that wind up
where somebody has granted it they
didn't revoke it and now once they're
penetrated they've got these escalated
privileges but that becomes only one
layer of the protection that's just
another layer the problem we have and I
see this in almost every codebase is
that complexity is the enemy we are
really worried about performance we're
really worried about elegant structures
we're really wanting elegant code but we
have this in situ right complex things
that create emergent behavior and
emergent behavior is behavior that
surprises you so something happens some
input comes into your system and you say
oh I didn't know it was gonna work that
way and that's and our customers and the
people who use our systems are very good
at giving us emergent behavior because
they use our systems in ways we never
really thought that they they would ever
be used but complexity also makes it
hard for us to reason about our code
because if you've ever listened to any
of Shawn parents no raw loops no raw
synchronization primitives talks
whenever you're talking about code that
is very complicated in the way it's put
together it's very hard for us to reason
about how that codes gonna behave under
certain circumstances and then
understandability the more complex
something is the more difficult it is
for the next person who comes in behind
you that has to maybe fix about trying
to figure out and I stole this from Bob
because he talked about this the other
day in fact I stole the word directly
from him we need to think about the way
we write code it's great to take
advantage of all of the new tools that
we have in modern C++ but when you write
code that is
so complicated that there's only one
human being in the entire company who
understands it we will lose situational
awareness on how that code behaves will
get emergent behavior and then we're
gonna get surprised the next thing is
logging we don't ever think about
logging I don't know about you but I
don't think about logging but one of the
problems we do with and they need an in
on the other other side of pattern when
you have an exception a lot of us will
just let it bubble the cotton top of the
call stack and then you won't read the
core file later or try and handle it
later one of the things that when we'll
look at here in just a minute one of the
things is the pattern of corrupt memory
tells us something where it's corrupted
tells us something so if you can catch
exceptions and log your memory into
something through that's easier for you
to consume than digging through a core
file it makes it much easier for you to
get to the answer quicker and find out
where the vulnerability is the other
thing we have to and talk about is what
we put into our logs we're not gonna
we're not gonna crypt our logs nobody
does that it's there is way too much
overhead but one of the things that if
you've ever gone through your lock ask
yourself how much could I determine from
my system by reading the logs that are
coming that come out of my system do I
put user names in it do I put
information that would let me track how
things are built within my system and
you obviously need to know it but the
more information that we put into them
these logs are usually unprotected which
means when someone's inside the wire
this first place I goes I'm gonna look
at their logs and see what's in it you
know how does the system run
and then audit trails now I've come from
a law enforcement background and from a
defense background where we needed to
have audit trails because I was either
dealing with evidence or I was dealing
with sensitive information and so I need
to know who touched that information and
was it changed from as it passes through
the system but if you treat logging as a
part of your security model which is
when I see certain exceptions or certain
things happening I'm logging them big
and bold so they're easy for me to grab
easy to find I'm not losing these
exceptions in the noise can be have any
questions so far
trust boundaries so yeah so the question
is is can I build an insecure trust
boundary absolutely you can build an
insecure anything fuzz testing security
testing penetration testing all the
things we've been covering up until now
trust boundaries are not exempt from
testing they are you've all a trust
boundary really is is I get data comes
in from some foreign source and by the
way everybody that comes into that is
considered a foreign source and I
validate the data I make sure that my
strings are null-terminated and then the
right size for the context those kinds
of things so yeah you can build in and
secure anything absolutely yes so the
comment was is that it's very hard to
build trust boundaries because today's
private interface becomes tomorrow's
public interface and that's absolutely
true
I'm more talking about third-party
libraries than I am standard template
libraries because STL is actually part
of the standard and one of the things
that's nice about the standard is that
cert is actively involved in the
standards committee so they're actually
in helping craft the language so that
the language is secure now STL is a
library but it's also a library that's
been extremely well tested it's pretty
well known I mean millions of Engineers
use it I'm more talking about
open-source libraries that are really
specific to some domain that you're in
that maybe it doesn't have as big a user
base it hasn't been through testing
nobody's fuzzed it it's just something
that is very specific to your domain
that you should not just because you're
using it trust it and the way you can do
that is to build a secure wrapper around
it so that you're catching exceptions
that are coming out you're validating
goat data going in you're validating the
data that comes out well so where do you
catch her the question was that or the
comment was is that you you do catch
exceptions anyway and where do you catch
those exceptions so where do you catch
your exceptions is at the top of the
call stack you just let it bubble up and
restart the app right so in this case a
security wrapper that goes around a
third-party library catches it as it
comes out of that library so you know
that's exactly where it came from and
you can protect against because their
code problems become your code problems
see I trust the code that I write and
Trust the code that my colleagues write
but I don't necessarily trust the
third-party libraries that come in so in
this case you're just insulating
yourself against somebody else's mistake
anything else so code reviews
everybody's favorite topic I don't know
about your experiences but my
experiences in the past have
that we tend to take it easy in Kotov
use we don't want to offend a colleague
we don't want to be overly harsh with a
colleague especially when they've got
some sort of a something that really
isn't the bug but maybe it's not done
the best way what we have to sort of get
and we do tend to focus on form and
function I don't like the name of your
variable years lying is too long what we
really need to focus on is correctness
because correctness is part of security
performance yes we all care about
performance but also about the security
of what you're writing
are you validating or do you know that
the data has been validated upstream
from you that you're not working on data
where you've lost situational awareness
the important thing though is is that
ruthlessness is a virtue in this case
because if you don't find the bug in a
code review some hackers gonna find it
six months later when you've forgotten
that it was actually there and you're
gonna have that moment oh you know I saw
that bug and I didn't say anything about
it the other thing is and this last one
I actually came from I did I've caught
myself doing this for a few times if you
guys use git and Gerrit so you check in
and then you you know everybody does a
review and so you've got some changes
you put out a second patch then may be a
third patch by the time you get three or
four patches
you add towards the after the initial
commit you sort of forgotten about what
the commit really was doing to the rest
of the of the code that it was being
checked into so one of the things that
I've stopped doing is that I don't +1
off an incremental commit I always go
and look at the entire commit in the
context of the code that it's modifying
instead of doing it off the last patch
that was checked in oh cuz yeah I see
they had this comment and they fixed
that comment so I don't know if anybody
else here does that but I've caught
myself letting things slip through a
couple of times and it's something that
I stopped doing so the comment was is
that's a shortcoming of the git review
process other code review tools to
ensure do you have a suggestion
looks like code collaborator brocaded
okay same so we have two other options
for code review tools I liked I liked
getting Garrett but it does write it
does have that vulnerability so the
other thing we need to look at as far as
code of uses legacy code I don't like
working in legacy code I don't know
about the rest of you I avoid it when I
can but it often has the worst
vulnerabilities especially the longer
the older that code has gotten the worse
the vulnerabilities are going to be in
it
fuzz testing and all the other testing
we will do does catch a lot of these you
find a lot of it and legacy code it
becomes one of those I didn't know that
was there but legacy codes really not
reviewed because nobody likes to touch
it it's almost radioactive so so
nobody's really going to go back and
review it yet
that hides a lot of vulnerabilities so
one of the things I would implement is
actually taking time to go back and
review your legacy code from a security
aspect your ups and you don't always see
if you had a static a check or run on
it'll obviously go through the same
process but a lot of times a second set
of eyes will catch things and I've had
this I've checked things in and I've had
a second set of eyes and I just missed
it yeah throw it away so so so the
question was any suggestion for multiple
decades long codebase throw it away and
start over I'm glad that's your problem
that's not the one I've got but code we
consider legacy today back then what did
they do that it became that has this
reputation of being having abilities
right so the question was is that code
you write today will be legacy code
tomorrow and what keeps us from writing
the the same vulnerabilities into the
code
tell me if I'm getting is wrong that it
becomes legacy code at some point time
knowledge that's why I'm doing this talk
probably few people in here and vector
when I asked who's got a security
program in place there was like three of
our hands the more we get the knowledge
out the more we think about this the
better the code will write today so then
when it becomes legacy code in the
future we don't have those
vulnerabilities behind us where we're
not expecting them so I know we don't
think about it and I'll talk about this
here in just a minute we don't tend to
think about security because it's really
not the most glamorous part of our job I
mean we get kudos for writing a really
great algorithm or writing a really fast
data structure but we really don't think
about security until we get burned then
the last thing is libraries you don't
write we talked a little bit about open
source everybody here use open source so
- the bad guys so one of the places we
need to go in code reviews is to make
sure that we're code reviewing our
third-party libraries is anybody in here
ever gone in third car code reviewed a
third-party library they're using one
two should do the entire library always
awesome yeah most people will do a piece
but not the whole thing you did always
so you're the trust but verify you have
to verify these things with code reviews
you have to go and look at the code you
you need to know how it works under the
hood because if the static analyzer
doesn't hit it if the fuzz testing
hasn't gotten a test case that exactly
matches what's going to kick that
vulnerability out use the best pattern
matching system you've got which is your
own brain to go code review that code
and then favor libraries that have
security audits so I don't know if
anybody keepin well this is booze con so
everybody keeps up with it but there's a
new library called beast they got put in
by Vinnie Falco one of the things Vinnie
did was he actually went out and had a
security audit run on the code I'm gonna
venture to guess most of boost has not
had that do you know you don't know or
no it hasn't no no it hasn't yeah and
yet boost is ubiquitous I mean I use it
but if you'd be if we begin favoring
third-party liar or open source
libraries that have been secured you
test if that brings the pressure back to
people who are putting those
libraries outside we're not gonna use a
library til it's got gone through
security on it every commit because just
because it passed now just cuz beast is
pretty good now I think they found two
vulnerabilities one was minor one was a
medium vulnerability they thought the
minor could be left the medium when he
fixed but what happens a year from now
after he's had a whole bunch of commits
so best practices I said this before
validates your data if you want to cut
out the overwhelming majority of
exploits that people will run up against
your code make sure that you maintain
situational awareness on your data if
you don't that's where you're going to
get burned the architecture would be
fantastic and have all the security in
the world but it will be the data that
you're working on it's going to be your
Val your your vulnerability I know some
people already do this treat warnings as
errors in the same way that pain in our
bodies tells us something if broken
warnings in our code tells us something
is inconsistent there's a reason why
those warnings are there the problem is
is that those warnings often get ignored
I've seen code roll out that's got 1,500
warnings and this isn't products that
used every day in the field you're not
going to be able to go from 1500 to zero
in a commit what you're going to have to
do and what I've what we've had good
success of the past is you're not
allowed to add more warnings in your
code then you can fix and the ones that
you add get scrutinized even more to
make sure there's nothing that you can't
do to remove that warning some of them
you live with but if you treat them all
as well as errors then those
inconsistencies that are in your product
will not become the vulnerability
someone can exploit later design it
always starts with the design if you're
designing a new system the first thing
you have to think about is your security
model that's permissions authentication
who's going to be talking to our IPC
mechanisms am I putting CL eyes on my
hardware the best thing you can do is
don't put CL eyes on your hardware if
you have field technicians that need it
give that to them let them go and just
run it in place off of USB or off of
some other capabilities so that they can
use it but it's not sitting on the box
so we can't be used to compromise your
system establish a code stay on a coding
standard everybody here have a coding
standard that's more than just line
length and names and really no it has to
include security becoming familiar with
these kinds of having internal training
becoming familiar with these kinds of
vulnerabilities will save you from
putting them in your code but also
codifying them in a coding standard so
that you're you're avoiding certain tiya
certain classes of vulnerabilities will
make a huge difference in your ability
to get the code out without there being
a vulnerably something to take advantage
of we talked about static analysis tools
penetration fuzz test and unit testing
the big thing is get buy-in from above
to make sure this is a really really
strict it this is probably one of the
hardest things because you have a
deadline and any suggestions so every
time I have to have this conversation
with somebody it usually comes down to
this
if you don't secure your company and
your software three things are going to
happen one they're going to get inside
is guarantee it two they're going to
figure out how to get into your banking
system which means they're going to go
after your money after they've gone
after your money
you're going to miss payments to
creditors miss your payroll and declare
bankruptcy you can't think about
security in sort of a context of the
same way we think about well what are
the odds somebody's gonna die on an
airplane you know where we have
actuarial tables to it if if your
company is using an actuarial a approach
to deciding whether or not they want to
implement security in their systems they
are just begging to get hit show them
this talk take the material from this
talk put your own talk together go
inside your company because you need
buy-in from above and below and that's
really the last two things educate
yourself train your team you don't want
to be the security guy it's absolutely
the worst position you can begin because
you're always the person who is pointing
out problems
and what winds up happening is is when
you don't get hit and they have a
security program you don't get hit
people say well where does he do all day
and we're good nothing's happened when
you get hit and someone gets inside it's
like what does he do all day I mean we
just got it it's the worst place you can
ever be what you want is an
organizational shift which you want us
to put together the Evanson I don't know
who the the question was you know how do
you how do you get this change in your
organization a lot of it depends on your
organization I'm working I've worked
with companies before that have been
through this they've seen just how bad
is it so it's a easy conversation to
have I mean they're all I mean nothing
makes my job easier trying to get a
company to implement a security plan
like a hacker who got inside the wire on
him and just wrecked things so the
comment was if you can find a really
good security guy grab him get him in
your company because this gentleman has
somebody in his company to put in all
these best practices penetration testing
fuzz testing all of these other things
and that's true I mean it's we would
never leave our house open we would
never leave the car unlocked in a major
Metro we'd never leave our money sitting
in the living room floor yet we it's
amazing how stupid we can be at the
corporate level where we don't think
about securing what is really the most
important thing you have which is your
job and the company that you're
responsible for guiding and I'm sure
that the CEO of Equifax thought they had
a really good program and then some
hacker wound up showing them just how
bad they were so the other thing to
remember is you have to be committed
doing this from an organizational level
look whether you like it or not whether
I like it or not we've just gotten
drafted into the front lines of a war
that is between us and them for some
definition of them and that's the way it
is it shirts and skins it's us in them
and we can look at it as well you know
what are we going to
Dumon after all we have to do all this
other work or we can look at this as a
challenge the same challenge that we
would look at if we're going to go and
build some brand new system what we have
to see this as is that when they're in
our software on our network in our
environment we're the Eagle not the
kitty and if we will look at it from
that viewpoint and see this is the
challenge that is is we will stop
looking in this as an additional duty we
have to do and now it's just something
we do in order for our companies to
survive the thing that you have to
understand and this is where the
commitment comes in is you will never
know if you've gotten it right you will
only know when you get it wrong so the
fact that you haven't been hacked in two
years is absolutely irrelevant because
your code base is changing you're adding
new stuff new features you will always
know when you've got it wrong but you'll
never know when you've got it right so I
have 15 minutes left do I have any more
questions because I wanted to show you
this demo the demo ok so so I have a VM
here yes charlie I have a password on my
VM which by the way is password pas SW
already all lowercase so if anybody's
thinking I'm gonna go hack his VM yeah
you got the password Ari
okay so I'm sorry no well yes because
it's sitting on my box here and that's
connected to Wi-Fi
okay so I've just created a few programs
here so vulnerability if you notice
there's a file called vulnerable that's
actually running his route which is not
atypical for something in an operating
system you can think of this as
something else that would be a something
run with higher escalation higher
privileges and then you are
I have my very bad code which all it
does is just read bad file better okay
awesome okay I'm gonna sit down sorry
cameraman but it's hard to okay so I
have my very bad code this is actually
the bad copy is actually the same code
we saw before that had the vulnerability
in it we're coming in with a length
we're not checking it we're just
slamming it right into the buffer the
bottom part in main just reads just
reads the the file and then calls Matt
now I'm gonna do one thing because I
actually have a better graphic that will
show you Oh
five C's I can make this bigger no we go
all the way to the end of the slide deck
sorry is there I have no idea what it is
I've used this right there okay so this
is gonna be a bit different strategy
what we're going to do is we're not
going to we don't have a nice big buffer
in our in our function that we can
operate it's only 24 bytes so what we're
going to do is we're actually run it
against the buffer that's above in main
so it's a bit different so I've added a
little more information in here main has
parameters and the buffer and then when
we called the the bag copy we have the
arguments the return address and then
the the frame and then and then our
buffer and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna start from our buffer we should
know right all the way up but we're
going to put the payload at the end up
in Maine and let me go back down here so
keep that in mind and we don't want to
update now that would be unfortunate so
let's look at better probably not no
ctrl+ better never break it see okay so
bad file will just hex dump bad file so
you notice up here we have what looks
like our address and that's true we're
overriding the address we're filling up
the buffer we have plus the return plus
EB P plus all the parameters and we're
covering B's and this is this is why we
have that big block is so we don't have
to have pinpoint accuracy and then you
have our no op slide followed by at the
very end you can see the vulnerability
so if the stars align when I run the
vulnerability I have a different prompt
and I say Who am I
I'm route and if I want to look at the
shadow file which I can't normally I now
can look at the shadow file so I've used
a buffer overflow run to exploit - hey
I'm just huh
basically we're all the password
information is stored it's the one file
if you really want to break all the
passwords in the system on a Linux
system you want the shadow file this
this is something that only root can
access or something with those
particular privileges can access so one
of the things why this becomes so
devastating is the fact that I now have
root access I can do anything I want on
this box wipe the hard drive anything
and then once I exit out of it if I were
to try and go and cat the shadow file I
permission dines because I'm back at me
I ran a 32-bit VM because it was easier
and the question was what are the
the things I had to turn off besides
running up 30 22 try and turn off a SLR
and I had to compile this so that it
wasn't doing any of the safe stacked
stuff in the background so this would be
and I made it just to make it easier on
myself because it's more important that
you see how these work not necessarily
that I can get past all of the things
which I'm sure if I put my mind to it I
could do it it was more important to put
the talk together than try and figure
out how you pass this but let's let's
look at the one other thing here let's
say I have another one that is exploit
fail because and and all that's going to
do and if you look at the size types all
that's doing is that it's is that's
creating a bad file that's now 200 bytes
long it's much smaller file what you'll
find is when someone is trying to
penetrate your systems they're going to
fail a lot because it takes time to
figure out where to get that buffer to
to find the sweet spot so let's go run
vulnerability now and we get a seg fault
why cuz I'm overriding in from memory
that it's really needing but it's
actually it's not overriding it with the
right memory so if we go into gdb and
we're gonna run vulnerability and we
want our we should have a core file here
yep so now we want to go in and we want
to look at the back trace so we have
four frames that we need what there is
there's main bag copy and then two
others so what do you look for when you
want to find whether or not why this is
crashing and if it's part of the
vulnerability so let's just look at our
bag copy frame first so now we're
actually in that frame then we want to
probably not why do you want me to go to
attack peanuts don't see what you see
what source oh I didn't compile with the
symbols in so it's we're not gonna show
the source and that's actually not what
you want to look at what you want to
look at is the stack
so let's look at the stack and see what
is there helps if it's a dollar sign so
the data on the stack sort of looks
unremarkable I mean there really isn't
anything in there that sort of points in
one direction or another so let's try
going up a level and see because
remember I ran my I ran it against Maine
up into the main stack so if I run the
same thing again I look at main stack
notice all the hex 90s so what your
what's interesting here is all these hex
90s and then you've got the repeated
addresses up top exactly that's the sled
you're gonna have hex 90s in your code
here and there if you go put something
in a pile or Explorer you will see hex
90s they'll be onesies and twosies but
if you ever get into this situation
you're looking at the stack of something
that is crashed and you're seeing hex
90s in blocks like this that's a dead
giveaway that somebody's actually trying
to probe your system to see if they can
run a buffer overflow explain now
there's other buffer overflow exploit
don't get me wrong this isn't the only
way to do it this was just the easiest
way to do it so the comment was there's
a main waste encoder no op what are they
okay so typically though if you're using
a no op sled in a buffer like this
you're going to see these hex - not now
well no not okay so the comment was is I
won't see them now because I've told you
what to do this is actually old school
stuff this is like back in the early
2000s
yeah what you'll see if you've got these
things turned on is they'll actually
tell you you're running gdb and you dump
your core file it's going to show you
that your stack was corrupted
what I'm the point I'm trying to make
here is that how when you deal with
corrupted memory how that memory is
corrupted tells you something and we
need to listen to it okay
other questions actually back here what
you're looking for in this and this is
where sort of the open source part of it
comes in is that if you're in a stack
frame you already know where the stack
frame begins what you're looking for is
an ad you're actually looking for an
address that's close because that's
where you want to put you that's the the
pointer you want to point is back into a
buffer that's actually fairly close to
you I played with it and it was it was
much it's trial and error
I mean bank yeah that's what that that's
how they used to do it anyway that's
really how they do it now it's just more
complicated to do this kind of an
exploit
simply because that we've added a SLR
we've added stat guards and all the
kinds of things sorry I didn't either so
the question is most of the overruns are
not on the stack I don't necessarily
think that's true yes you can you can do
heap overruns you can also do pointer
code pointer exploits which are going to
be somebody creates a structure there's
you know some data above it you overflow
that buffer there happens to be a
pointer right below it that's actually a
function pointer and now you're
executing arbitrary code this is these
kinds of exploits are actually I mean it
takes certain mind to think these things
through and to have a really in-depth
understanding of the it took me a while
to learn how to do something like this
just because I don't deal in this on any
given day I've got other domains that I
have to to deal in and you had a
question
you had your hand up did you have a
question okay you're just scratching
something okay any other questions okay
great thank you for coming
[Applause]